okay if waited long enough open your  damn present Fantastic look look at that  look at that huh wow  what are you waiting for open it oh I'm  just waiting for everyone else to open  their presents first it's literally just  us here can you open it all right all  right let's see let's see here by the  way are we going to dinner tonight I  totally forgot I don't no open your  press I'm opening it I'm opening I'm  just giving it one second this is darn  tape it's just like it's sticky as heck  you can just Dive Right In it's not  don't you don't have to  it's a puzzle look it's like half  focused you can see it it's a puzzle  it's a puzzle it's a puzzle ah oh it's a  it's a puzzle all right can we go but I  have one of these already though shoot